welcome to the Dave Ramsey show we're
glad you're here open phones America at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jerome is in Philadelphia hey
Jerome how are you hey I you Don Dave
better than I deserve man what's up
problem is I have two daughters and my
girlfriend and I I'm thinking about
buying a car and right now we do over
live and we spend maybe i'ma say maybe
400 bucks a month on that along and I'm
thinking I can use that money and
finance a vehicle you don't own a
vehicle no no no what's your household
income when me and her could probably
make about about forty eight thousand
over here okay well we would always
suggest that you avoid debt always so
okay because here's the thing the the
car payment is the it's a payment on the
largest thing that most people buy that
goes down in value it's going down in
value and you're paying payments for the
opportunity to ride around in it now I
agree with you that if you're spending
four hundred bucks a month on uber and
lyft something's probably needs to give
I don't have an issue with that but that
doesn't mean we need to turn around
spend $250 on a car payment because
that's gonna lock you in and you know
you're gonna be trapped it's gonna eat
your money up let's think about it
another way where are you guys going in
a given month on uber and lyft what are
the types of trips you're doing well for
me I work out five days a week and
there's no and he's close to weather is
it really bad now so I do it through a
phone work the kids appointments my
girlfriends works at Bank area so she
would take one to take my youngest
daughter to her mom's house and from
there so go to work so is this a lot of
work and school
okay well what what I would try to do if
I were in your shoes I mean if we could
figure out a way to for one or two
months do this super cheap using public
transportation maybe some friends
helping out or something else just just
for a very short period of time two
months maybe you should be able to put
together a thousand dollars okay and if
you put together a thousand dollars you
get you a little hoop deke are not
nothing not even great a thousand dollar
car right I mean this isn't much but at
least you own it and you have no
payments now you can drive anywhere you
want to drive now are we gonna drive a
thousand dollar car for the rest of your
life no you're not
alright no you're not but we're gonna
drive it for a couple more months and
every month that you don't have Oberer
and every month that you don't have a
car payment you should be able to save
five hundred dollars right because
you're spending 400 now so if you get on
a written budget and really make your
money behave and you have this one car
and you make it work
if you drive a thousand dollar car for
two months you'll have another thousand
bucks and you could buy two thousand
dollar car then and you do this for two
more months and are four more months you
would be in a four thousand dollar car
and so I'm only talking about six months
of driving you know some crappy cars and
then you're in a pretty diet and pretty
dadgum nice car and and you could pay
cash for it and not have car payments
the reason I would fight so hard to do
that if I were in your shoes is and by
the way I've been in your shoes although
they didn't have uber and lyft back then
the reason I fight so hard is all
everything I know about handling money
says that people who have car payments
never win financially you just don't
find millionaires with car payments oh
and I want you to I want you to have
some money you know but if you give it
all the bank by just being what's
convenient doing what's convenient it's
convenient I mean you can't rot down
there and get your car they'll give you
a car today and you put on payments and
you'll be just like everybody else broke
with car paint
it's and then you'll be trying to figure
out a way to get out of car payments and
I've just got to recommend man that you
try to figure out some way to you know
gut your way through this first couple
of steps here in $2,000 $2,000 a car and
then move up and then move up if you
maybe you got a relative to loan you an
old car for a month or two you know just
for a short period of time not forever
just for a month or two just to help us
get rid of this uber and lyft bill so we
can turn around and use that same money
to save and pay cash for a little car to
get around with and then move up and
then move up pay yourself a car payment
$500 a month then move up pay yourself a
car payment of $500 a month and then
move up pay yourself a car payment of
$500 and then move up I mean you do this
for five or ten months 10 months is
$5,000 that's a lot of money